one more important thing right do you
remember we said here if you're
switching inputs and output it's a
little bit like you know one guy who
adds these things about think about
these two as um two different people
doing different things okay so this guy
adds something on this guy takes him
away yeah this guy doubles stay harps
now if you put these two people together
you combine them what will the net
result be there will be no change right
like whatever number you started with
let's let's take a number
let's go like say x equals one okay yeah
add two which gives you three and then
you take away two which brings you back
to one okay and you can do this with any
of the examples okay so how carefully
that sort of cancelling out that net
result zero
how would you stake that with all of
what we've got on the board right now
we've got the notation understand to be
able to articulate in a much more
succinct way to ventas you've got two
guys arguing in so the idea of an
average is tricky I think that's
actually correct that's fine like you
put these two together which is one
meaning of the word average okay
the problem with average is that will
average despite the name actually
contains a whole variety different
things is an arithmetic average as a
geometric average there's a logarithmic
courage there's all a bunch of different
averages so even though that works I
want to be a little more precise I'm
gonna get this guy here this is the
reason why we introduced notation so we
can use it to articulate what is going
on okay if I had to take a function and
then I'm going to apply its inverse as
well right it's a little bit like saying
here's a function we said one before
right
we said one okay and then that's a
number do you agree with that like it
might be three or it might be e or two
or okay you get the idea
right that's a number and now I'm going
to apply the inverse to that so what
would that look like in this notation
now in order to apply a function to
something I say f of that like well I
want to do an inverse function to that
that's my new number yeah there we go
now this means you take the number you
put it through the first function like
this
and then you take that number and you
put it into the inverse function right I
want to do it backwards gonna do this
one first how would I write aha yeah I'm
gonna go F of F inverse of whatever
number in fact I'd end up the same one I
just picked that one cuz I could
computer I could stand for any number
right now what we're suggesting what we
said with the example of one is that you
should land back on where you started
right if you've gotten the inverse right
that should be what happens can you test
that let's test it I'm going to meet
this for a second because you actually
have this in your bores by the way that
you should totally have written down
okay as any day what let's go example
one okay if I said I'm gonna go with f
of X being X plus two and it's inverse
being X minus two
what would F of F inverse let's do it in
this one first I'm just gonna do a
straight substitution first if that's
okay and inverse I know exactly what
that is I to find that one line ago okay
so this is actually F or X minus two
like that's what f inverse is just the
definition so now I applied the original
function to it right which means
everywhere I see
the X I'm gonna replace it with an X
minus two but does that make sense
that's what I'm inputting okay
so it's X minus two plus two there's the
first function which of course is just X
right
simple another example let's do the logs
the Exponential's right if I say what's
the other direction if we go to the logs
and Exponential's now if our exponential
function was the exponential I was the
original function okay so I'm gonna say
log base e of e to the X
yeah this is where I find take that out
that's just x times one it works right
hmm
we did this guy will it work can you try
it I'll give you 30 seconds down
which I have to think about why exactly
that does that why cuz I partly in fact
that's that's the donation that's what
should do you don't really that's why
you have to give up a leg one to it and
say there's an original and there's a
universe this is why we introduced the
whole F inverse notation precisely so we
can do this so if you like let's call
this because we did start with it
let's call what we started with the
original why let's call that F okay
which means huh doesn't matter really
because f inverse is we determined it
was the same function didn't win okay so
whichever way you do it and I'm
interested maybe I mean you've already
started but you could do it either way
that's what we were trying to say before
right in this case it's symmetrical
right so it doesn't matter which way you
get it so if I did say this this is what
it would look like
that should be a first-line right geez
that's just the substitution how look
how many lies until you get there - did
you multiplexer it is that what you did
what did you make - yeah I can show I've
been a multiply top and bottom by X
minus one that eliminates the numerator
sorry the denominator there and it
introduces an X minus one yeah why am I
putting brackets because the next time I
do it those may be signs are gonna send
me first in right okay what am I getting
here on the of course one minus negative
one